a massive fire ripped through the set of
a major Hollywood movie in New York City
last night killing a firefighter and
badly burning two others
the fire started in a building that was
being used to shoot a movie starring
Edward Norton Bruce Willis and Alec
Baldwin 37 year-old firefighter Michael
Davidson a father of four was killed
while fighting the flames vladimir
duthiers of our streaming network cbsn
is at the scene in harlem vlad what a
horrifying scene that is good morning
good morning bianna indeed it is you can
still see the chart out remains of the
building right behind me here and you
can see the king rooster this was a
refurbished set that was being used for
the Ed Norton film motherless Brooklyn
neighbors say that that set is being
refurbished and now you can see it's
been completely burned out here's the
thing that's really important to note
neighbors and sets folks on the set say
that they started smelling smoke just as
they were wrapping up shooting the
five-alarm fire erupted late last night
in the cellar of a building in West
Harlem the flames are shooting out real
intense and you go through the heat real
real bad the flames were coming through
the roof looked like essentially like a
volcano smoke and flames quickly poured
out of the brownstone which was being
used for filming his smoking was come
from the bismuth Ambrose iron fence a
background actor in the movie motherless
Brooklyn says they were wrapping up
shooting on the ground level of the
building when they started the see smoke
rising he did narrative up here
everybody from de sift Lee and we all
get out director Edward Norton was seen
looking on as flames engulfed the
building the FDNY says firefighter
Michael Davidson was one of the first to
arrive on scene Davidson was separated
from the rest of the unit as he battled
the flames in the cellar he later died
our entire department our entire city
mourns the serife across of a very brave
firefighter
the FDNY says the cause of the fire is
still being investigated in a statement
the producers of motherless Brooklyn
said their hearts go out to the family
of the firefighters and they called the
FDNY real-life heroes gale real-life
heroes indeed thank you very much lead